knock it off I'm conducting this
interview no that's not what you said
when I came in here you said that I was
conducting the interview now exactly how
much pot did you
smoke I want it on my desk by the end of
the day or you will receive a full
disadulation what's
that I love the way John cracks hey if
Sabre truly cared about a long-term
well-being they would set up hand
desanitizing stations hold up what's a
hand desanitizing station bowl of dirt
okay you
understand this is oh my
God that's a good impro okay you
understand the more we expose ourselves
to germs the
stronger don't make me pre-fire you you
wouldn't
dare oh man and when I get promoted
you're full fired if you get promoted
ah don't make me pre-fire you you
wouldn't dare you're pre-fired and when
I'm promoted you're full fired if you're
promoted
Sho oh it's just like the old days hey
Dwight oh
the mall is corrupt mall is evil they
appearances
okay Jim that is so
inappropriate this is the baby's
learning everything this is when it
imprints M you know not careful all of a
sudden the baby thinks that it's
refrigerator is its father is that what
happened to you I'll tell you what
happened to
me I'll tell you what happened to me I
didn't see my father for the first two
years of his life of his
life Kevin will be eaten Pam will be
taken slave Andy will be made a
warlord's Jester and Meredith will do
just fine what can I
do your skull will
be let try
again what can I do your skull will be
made of soup
[Laughter]
bowl what can I do your skull will be
made of soup bowl
cool what's going on what could I
do your I'm sorry I'm sorry what can I
do your skull will be a soup bowl
cool all right here you go anything else
else I can do thank you you're
welcome I tried to do some research once
MOS and I rented a movie about a Latina
wedding planner with a big fat
ass moose and I rented a movie about a
Latino wedding planner with a big fat
ass I tried to do some research
once
we just wanted to say we're very sorry
screw you guys you're dead to me if you
say screw you one more time screw you
beat who okay
guys I did that face you like if you say
screw you one more time screw you be
guys stop doing that it makes no sense
if you say screw you one more time screw
you be hey guys just cool
it you knew you knew that one was dead
basically the Dynamics
of all right basically within the
[Laughter]
workplace
oh there's always a theme
idiot
I'm sorry we only take MasterCard or
Diner Club you take Diner Club come on
come on here we
go what are you doing
here wait wait I still want to quit but
if I quit we'll all quit it'll be
[Music]
Anarchy I still want to
quit but if I quit we'll all
quit I so want to quit but if I quit
we'll all quit
it'll does this even work Jimbo last
chance to
carpool all right you want a car
poool car pool yep little car pool
together we're going go separately s
what we car pull together
yeah going
seaming
no carpool we carpool together
yeah I'll meet you
there
okay it won't
open I'm
burped my uncle Harvey shro is a fudge
packer he works at the Hershey
factory I am hoping to find whoever
committed this heinous
deed and I am
praying that I find this heinous
culprit I will pray to Thor
himself I'm not only hoping to find the
culprit of this heinous
crime
I am not only hoping to find the culprit
of this heinous crime I am praying to
find the heinous
culprit I am not only hoping to find the
culprit of this heinous
crime I am praying to find
this I'm not only hoping to find the
culprit of this heinous crime I am
praying
[Laughter]
I am not only hoping to find the culprit
of this heinous crime I am praying to
find this heinous culprit and I will
pray
to I'm sorry I'm
not okay I can do it know you
can't
think